IN THIS HORRIFIC MASSACRE.
>> Tucker: RICK, THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
I APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
>> ALWAYS A PLEASURE, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: A STUDENT AT
MARJORY STONEMAN DOUGLAS WHERE
THE SHOOTING OCCURRED, TRAPPED
IN A CLASSROOM WHEN THE S.W.A.T.
TEAM STRUGGLED LOOK AND
STRUGGLED TO GET HER OUT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
WHAT DID YOU EXPERIENCE TODAY?
>> THE LAST 20 MINUTES OF CLASS
THERE WAS A FIRE DRILL, BUT IT'S
REALLY WEIRD RIGHT AWAY, BECAUSE
WE JUST HAD ONE THIS MORNING, SO
EVERYONE ALREADY KNEW THAT
SOMEBODY HAD EITHER PULLED IT OR
IT WAS SET OFF, AND IT COULD NOT
HAVE BEEN RINGING FOR MORE THAN
5 MINUTES, MORE THAN 2 MINUTES,
BECAUSE THAT BY THE TIME I HAD
REACHED THE STAIRWELL IT HAD
ALREADY STOPPED, AND EVERYBODY
STOOD THERE NOT KNOWING EXACTLY
WHAT TO DO AND WE JUST KIND OF
LOOKED AROUND UNTIL WE HEARD
THREE OR FOUR LOUD BANGS AND
EVERYONE WHO WAS GOING DOWN THE
STAIRS AND RAN BACK UP, AND
ABOUT I WANT TO SAY OVER 100
STUDENTS JUST TRYING TO RUN INTO
A CLASSROOM AND SHUT THE DOOR.
THERE WERE KIDS IN MY CLASS
RUNNING THROUGH THE CORNER AND
JUMPING OVER DESKS AND TRYING TO
GET BEHIND THE TEACHER'S DESK
AND IT WAS A MESS OF --
>> Tucker: WAS THE TEACHER IN
THE ROOM?
>> MY TEACHER WAS NOT THERE
TODAY.
WE HAD A SUB, AND YOU COULD TELL
THAT HE DID NOT KNOW WHAT TO DO.
AT FIRST SHE THOUGHT IT WAS SOME
KIND OF MESSED UP DRILL.
BUT THEN WE STARTED TO SMELL
STUFF LIKE SMOKE AND GUNPOWDER,
AND OUR PARENTS WERE CALLING US
AND FREAKING OUT AND CALLING
BUT THEN OTHER KIDS WERE
SHUSHING THEM TO BE QUIET.
IT SEEMED LIKE WE WERE THERE FOR
HOURS, BUT JUST NOT KNOWING
ANYTHING OR WHAT WAS GOING ON.
ONLY HEARING THE SIRENS OUTSIDE.
>> Tucker: DID YOU LOCK THE
DOOR?
>> THE DOOR WAS ALREADY LOCKED.
>> Tucker: DID YOU HAVE YOUR
PHONE WITH YOU?
>> YES.
MY VERY FIRST INSTINCT WAS TO
TAKE A VIDEO OF THE SOUND AND
SEND IT TO MY PARENTS AND TELL
THEM THAT I AM OKAY IN THE
CLASSROOM.
>> Tucker: DID THEY RESPOND?
>> YES, ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
>> Tucker: WHAT DID THEY SAY?
>> BOTH OF THEM WERE JUST VERY
CONFUSED AND ASKING ME IF I WAS
OKAY AND WHERE I WAS AND WHAT
BUILDING I WAS IN.
AND IF I KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
JUST KEEP TALKING TO THEM NO
MATTER WHAT.
>> Tucker: SO YOU TEXT THEM
WHILE THE SHOOTING IS GOING ON,
THEY TEXTED YOU BACK.
THEY MUST HAVE JUST BEEN
PANICKED.
WHAT WAS YOUR REUNION LIKE WITH
YOUR PARENTS?
>> UM, AS SOON AS I LEFT THE
SCHOOL I WAS CROSSING THE STREET
AND THEY KEPT HAVING US TURN
AROUND.
I WAS ON THE PHONE WITH MY MOM
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE SHE
WAS, BUT SHE SAID SHE WAS GOING
TOWARDS THE END, AND AS SOON AS
I SAW HER EYE JUST RAN TO HER,
AND MY DAD RAN.
MY LITTLE SISTER WAS THERE AND
WE WERE JUST CRYING AND HUGGING
EACH OTHER.
>> Tucker: THAT IS AN
EMOTIONAL -- JUST EMOTIONAL
THINKING ABOUT THAT.
YOU WERE LED OUT OF THE
CLASSROOM AND THE SCHOOL BY A
S.W.A.T. TEAM, WHAT DID YOU SEE
ON YOUR WAY OUT?
>> I TRIED NOT TO LOOK, BUT
THERE WAS BLOOD AND GUNPOWDER
AND BODIES JUST ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
WE WERE STEPPING OVER PUDDLES OF
BLOOD AND JUST TRYING NOT TO
LOOK.
>> Tucker: SO ALL OF THE
STUDENTS IN THE CLASS THAT YOU
WERE AND GOT OUT SAFELY, IS THAT
CORRECT?
>> I AM PRETTY SURE, YES.
ALL OF THE STUDENTS THAT WERE IN
THE CLASS WITH ME WHEN THE DOOR
WAS SHUT ARE SAFE.
>> Tucker: HAD YOU HEARD OF
THE SHOOTER?
NIKOLAS CRUZ, HAD YOU HEARD THAT
NAME BEFORE?
>> NO, I HAD NEVER HEARD HIS
NAME OR MET HIM OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
HE IS A COMPLETE STRANGER TO ME.
>> Tucker: HE WAS EXPELLED
FROM YOUR SCHOOL, YOU DON'T KNOW
WHY?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: INTERESTING.
FINALLY, HEYLEE, HAVE YOU TALKED
TO YOUR CLASSMATES SINCE YOU
LEFT THE SCHOOL, HOW ARE YOU
DOING?
>> ONE OF MY BEST FRIENDS WAS
WITH ME IN THE ENTIRE TIME FROM
THE STAIRCASE TO THE CLASSROOM
TO LEAVING THE SCHOOL, AND WE
HAVE BEEN CHECKING UP ON EACH
OTHER, AND BOTH OF US JUST CAN'T
WRAP OUR HEADS AROUND WHAT
EXACTLY HAPPENED.
IT DOES NOT FEEL REAL.
AND SHE DOES NOT FEEL SAFE.
>> Tucker: I BET SHE DOES NOT.